clark county officially moving forward
with a plan to combat covid19
now this comes as the state starts its
process to give counties control
over local enforcement yeah brian and it
involves easing a lot of those
restrictions as our local positivity
rate still remains pretty low sasha
loftis spoke with many here in the
valley to see how they feel about the
changes and she joins us now live with
the latest
sasha denise and brian some i spoke with
say they're happy to see these
restrictions loosen while others believe
it's still
too soon i did speak with an expert
tonight as well who says we've come a
long way here in clark county
but we still have to be cautious he says
to
come back covet 19. this is a
very well thought out plan a plan is now
in place to ease covid restrictions
across clark county given the percentage
of
like success i don't think that we have
to worry too much some are all for the
proposal
but others say it's still too soon it
seems like
it might still be a little bit early to
drop restrictions the changes which were
approved
tuesday will increase capacity rates
decrease social distancing
and remove all guidelines once at least
60 percent of the population
receives at least one vaccine dose the
word is really hurt immunity
you know how close are we to that dr
jonathan bhaktari of e-7 health
says while relaxing some restrictions
make sense
we haven't reached herd immunity yet as
more and more
people at risk get vaccinated the real
marker is going to be
you know will the death you know
continue to drop he tells me it's still
important to protect
our most vulnerable as experts deal with
new virus variants
and learn how long that two-shot
protection will last
those are the two curve balls we have to
watch out for but those here in the
valley believe
we're moving in the right direction as
long as
everyone stays smart and safe just be a
little more cautious for a little bit
longer
now the county plan will go to the state
for review if it is approved at that
level
it will go into effect here locally on
may 1st now as
for the mass mandate here in clark
county it will stay
in place at a state level for the
foreseeable future
reporting live in las vegas tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now